the u.n says registering refugees is
critical to ensuring they get assistance
and protection
800 000 rohingya refugees in bangladesh
gave personal information including
fingerprints to the unhcr beginning in
2017.
now human rights watch says that
information was improperly handled and
shared with myanmar
when they had their data taken by unhcr
this was part of a more general
registration process by the un agency
to give them access to the most basic
and essential services once they had
arrived in
in bangladesh and um what the government
in bangladesh issued for each of them
which is the smart card with some
biometric uh
information attached to it and in the
context of that unhcr decided to
also register these individuals um
for their data to be sent to myanmar now
what we found in our interviews
is that the people we spoke to all
except one had never even been
asked by by unhcr staff when being
registered in the field
whether they agreed to having their data
shared with myanmar
the unhcr has strongly denied any
wrongdoing
it insists consent was obtained from the
refugees at least twice
adding that when unhcr and the
government of bangladesh signed their
memorandum of understanding on data
sharing in january 2018
and organized their joint registration
exercise of rohingya refugees
specific measures were taken to mitigate
potential risks
al-jazeera has reached out to the
governments of bangladesh and myanmar
for comment
but received no reply in 2017 myanmar's
military launched a violent crackdown
against the rohingya
in rakhine state the u.n called it a
textbook example of ethnic cleansing
more than 700 000 rohingya escaped
across the border to southwestern
bangladesh
according to human rights watch during
the refugee registration process
some rohingya even raised concerns their
data would be used to send them back to
myanmar
the government of bangladesh has
repeatedly stated that repatriations
would only be carried out on a voluntary
basis
unhcr says it will assist refugee
returns if they are voluntary
and when conditions are favorable for a
safe and sustainable return
which is not the case at the moment but
for the rohingya
considered one of the world's most
persecuted minorities the worries are
constant
and they're not likely to ease in the
wake of a new report calling into
question
who may have had access to their
personal information
mohammed al jazeera